[Music]
you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to
life this Parker out with friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three one two
three there I did it for
you now you take it now I'm going to
burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is his is a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
bro don't
move
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scan the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem
no way he's coming to a street through
the back entrance I fig i' give the
firefighters a break somebody detain
this
guy we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as who
knew
going to
get I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I we're not so different
agent our guy
it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
copout whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book come
on
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked a
hornets nest you didn't even know
existed I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter
God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Ary oh my God oh my God oh my God
it needs a little work but I don't think
it's going to last long at this
price there's a
pool always wanted a
pool is this everything
we'll grow into
it y'all
ready
Marco
hello Marco
hello
Marco I I hear
you you need to say something
back Ronin
[Music]
Marco
Marco I can hear
you why aren't you saying anything
Ronin you're
dead
Marco
Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for are
you are
you coming to the
Tre The Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
B I just want to know that somebody
still cared about me that I was still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people then it's essential to accept
what human beings
are and what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people filled with a terve becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predator I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world your moners all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people mad
Mr snow let me ask you one final time
what are the Hunger Games
for a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree it's the things we love most that
destroy us
I've got plenty to be thankful
for I needs are small I buy them all at
the 5 and 10 cent store oh I've got
plenty to be thankful
[Music]
for
I used to love this
town until what happened that
night tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal
too show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is
an institution
here
[Applause]
no no
no someone's out for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holiday
game this is weird we're all tagged and
our names are at the table but why
[Music]
us
the longer this goes the more Twisted it
gets every weapon he's using is straight
off a Thanksgiving table I don't want to
spend my life looking over my shoulders
we need to stop
[Applause]
him
[Music]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving let's
see 4 years ago I was basically
unemployed The Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I'm know how you do it pops my job
was a little less stressful than
yours oh yeah I finally got a job I'm
the king of
[Music]
Atlantis
half a billion people from every known
species in the sea call this place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to
Ash he must be stopped for a global
meltdown is imminent
I think I know someone might go to help
us you look
rough good job little brother High fire
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king built Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trion during King alin's time there were
Seven
Kingdoms a trident was a curse upon them
all the trid and start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies said
but we can't leave our children a world
without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow hi what's your name Priscilla
Boer you like Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't one are the kids listening to
these day Bobby Darren Fabian and
[Music]
you just what is the intent here Mr
presy you got women throwing themselves
at you why my daughter well SAR I happen
to be very fond of your
daughter she's much more mature than her
age
21 22 that's
[Music]
you don't have to worry
[Applause]
bu black ha and more I
makeup I don't know if I like it what do
you mean you don't know if you're likey
it he's not like you
[Applause]
[Music]
imagin you know there's a lot of rumors
about
you
is there something you're
hiding I don't have a goddamn thing to
[Music]
hide I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen are you
going to be here or
[Music]
not I want a life of my
own
[Music]
shots fired shots fired all units please
respond
[Music]
no
this
f
all
this Barbarian blood tries your heart
because they look at you and Fs and full
of hope budika they must not find their
savior they believe that a woman warrior
will somehow be their
salvation Rome cannot and will not
recognize you as
[Music]
Queen oh people who asked the gods of
dant to provide us a leader and now they
[Music]
[Applause]
have we fight for our
freedom they are sending reinforc ments
that we cannot
defeat I cannot lose you know
that on this spot we must conquer oh
die I was a
fire I ain't
anymore what kind of price you got on me
kind that'll get you chased down no
matter where you
go I had your money big mom so is it I
lost it the only way for you to get me
paid is the oldfashioned way fight or
don't fight you might get hurt if you
do you will get hurt if you
[Music]
don't just take it I don't want to it's
the type of money that could change
somebody's life son of a gun the butcher
standing right here in front of me after
all these years you still fight
yeah the lady at the store said you were
a fighter that right once upon a time
why do you have to fight tonight long
story you ain't no good to me this but
you going to give me a fight you in a
big ho the god bigger when you started
dancing around Big Mama's Street you
can't fight it's not
you don't got to do this it's going to
be all
right there is this great big world out
there and sometimes it spins against
you but sometimes it spins you right
into what you
need I can't tell you what you want to
hear that guy will kill you but I'm not
leaving
you you used to be hell but
hell has caught up
[Applause]
yeah
yeah it's going to be a battle come
on and you don't look capable no more
capable of
what
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I need it was a love you
gave have you guys taken the test yeah 3
years ago we were positive felt like a
weight had been
lifted I founded this institute to take
the risk out of love no more uncertainty
no more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct the test to make the bond of
love
stronger I really want to work here
a lot of famous people study there
really like who Ginger Spice she's my
favorite I
know so you'll be shado air he's already
one of our most successful instructors
what's the one thing you love most about
Maria take your time I love her
hair it's soft it's nice answer it's
nice the truth is we're all achingly
lonely and we're endlessly searching for
ways to fill that void can I ask you
something why do you work at The
Institute maybe you understand love a
little
better I really want to learn how the
exercises help you connect why are we
doing this I thought it'd be fun it's
just messy that's
all I think it's normal to get into a
bit of a routine I think relationship
should be worked on every day oh sorry I
was wondering if it was possible that
one person could be in love with two
people at the same time it's a
biological impossibility yeah that's
what I thought
too I need to tell you
[Music]
something all I ever
knew only
you
[Music]
hello Joe
where let's discuss your new job what
job I got a wife and she's pregnant
please let me
go at Mard your work consists of pushing
the
mill failure to meet your daily quota
will result in a
punishment the employee with the fewest
points will be
[Applause]
terminated when do I go
home you are well on your
[Applause]
way oh
you still don't believe the rules
apply to
you perhaps you would respond to other
incentives you took everything from
me what is this you're still asking
questions walk through the door prepare
your mind for a transformative
experience by
malard you're a crucial part of our team
for
Life pressure is all right Gary it's
perfect
is there any area in particular you want
me to focus on today um Gary how many
guys have you done this with you're the
first guy that I've ever been intimate
with I had a wife she lefted I really
don't know what to say I mean words of
affirmation is not my love language it's
more
like I've been alive for nearly half a
century and I haven't actually lived
even a second of it Gary I'm going to
help you let's find someone for you oh
my God there's so many hot guys I think
that this might just be too much too
late he's already in his way wait
what Hello sup bro just want to get in
and get out oh you can get in all
right it's a gorgeous Landing what are
you doing oh I'm calling 911 Gary no
accidents happened it was your first
night being gay did you really think you
were going to make any mistake he
bled through the tar that's Mountain
Ashwood it's really porous oh my God
you're so
gay are you a cop no wait are you no
good good cuz the dark web's built on
trust come
on is this what it's like this is what
it's like I am like human poppers I open
anyone up I'm really glad I met
you even if multiple people are dead
because of
[Music]
it Church girls know how to
kneel it me where are you going
I am a cool hot zty where didd you kill
him oh we right outside you moved the
body in the closet you guys ever seen
Gone Girl Just aart with Ben stick
Gary Angel Falls I give you
Christmas the lights are so pretty this
is
perfect
[Music]
what did you
eat help me somebody please help me no
please wake
up Mar
Waters last Christmas still haunts
me time to let that go no one
cares everyone would be better off if I
was never
born did you see that did the power go
up oh my
God I stood under the Aurora and said
everyone would be better off if I never
existed well wish granted Angel strikes
every couple of weeks how can that be do
I know you it's Winnie you know that
okay this hurt hi hi I'm Henry Waters
you're safe now he's not going to get
you
no one in this town knows me who are you
dad you weren't around to stop him so he
just kept going he likes
killing I'm here now let's have some
fun hey you hey Merry
[Music]
Christmas we got to stop him and get my
life
back you be safe
now
next go wins is a true story about the
worst soccer team in the world American
sore I can honestly say it's the worst
bunch of players I've ever come across
all I want is just one goal one
goal I win this not knowing anything
about soccer and by the end of the film
I knew
less a story about triumph over
adversity that's really the thing that
attracted me to this soccer's not in
their DNA they're weak they are not
weak jump jump stop you go
around this is the ultimate Feelgood
Underdog
film it's fun it's uplifting and it's
about
Hope we've worked too long and hard for
this are you with me my team go my ankle
is
[Music]